THE STATE OF PRINTERS:
Printers are the worst of the worst.
They struggle to connect to the wifi, they
constantly have paper jams, and don’t get
me started at the ludicrous price of ink.
It seems that printers are one of the few
tech industries that have been completely
left behind.
I mean you can buy full on computers and smartphones
for less than the price of a new printer.
Yet, printers can’t even do the one task
that their built for: printing.
It’s easy to blame the printer industry
as a whole and say that printer companies
are simply unimaginative and not innovative.
But, the issue with printers is a lot more
deep rooted than uninspired companies and
lack luster products.
The real reason printers are so crappy is
due to decades of hyper focus on maximizing
revenue through one avenue: ink.
It’s not uncommon for printer ink to exceed
$80 per ounce.
For perspective, even human blood only costs
$17 per ounce and silver costs $34 per ounce.
In fact, selling ink is so profitable, that
it accounted for 63% of all of HP Inc’s
profits in 2019.
But, it wasn’t always like this.
In fact, 50 to 60 years ago, printers were
the creme of the crop.
They were the best that the tech world had
to offer and they worked beautifully.
Back in the 1960s, Xerox literally made a
commercial showcasing how even a chimpanzee
could operate a photocopier.
Printer operators were so insulted after this
airing that Xerox would decide to cancel the
commercial just one day later.
But, that doesn’t take away from the message
of the commercial.
Printers were once easy enough for trained
chimpanzees to use, but today even trained
rocket scientists at NASA can’t figure out
how to operate these darn things.
So, what happened?
How did printers go from being the forefront
of the tech industry and the entire business
of one of the biggest companies in the world
Xerox to being the laughing stock of the tech
industry and the endless frustration of hundreds
of millions of office workers around the world?
Well, sit back and grab a stress ball because
this is exactly how printers became the bane
of our existence.
WHEN PRINTERS WERE GOOD:
Taking a look back, printers are by no means
a new invention.
It’s theorized that printers may date as
far back as 3500 BC to the Persians and Mesopotamians
who used cylinders to seal documents similar
to what we do today.
But, the modern printing press didn’t come
around till the year 1440 when a German goldsmith
named Johannes Gutenberg invented the movable-type
printing press.
At the time, this was a true revolution as
the alternative was hand printing which was
limited ot about 40 pages per day.
Gutenberg’s printing press put that number
to shame as it could produce 3600 pages every
single day.
Over the next couple hundred years, the printing
press became the gold standard for printing
religious literature, newspapers, and books.
But eventually moving into the 1900s, there
arose a new purpose for printing.
People and corporations alike needed an easy
way to copy existing documents at a small
scale.
They wanted to have additional copies of their
bond and land certificates and their employment
contract.
But, while the printing press was great at
replicating a given piece of text like a Bible
at scale, it wasn't all the great when it
came to replicating individual documents and
pages.
Chester Carlson, a law student in the late
1930s knew this pain all too well.
You see, Chester couldn’t afford to buy
law books outright, so he would go to the
library and painstakingly transcribe books
onto sheets of paper.
It was during one of these arduous copying
sessions that he came across a scientific
article by a Hungarian physicist named Pal
Selenyi.
Selenyi loosely described how you could use
physics and more specifically electrophotography
to duplicate documents more effectively.
It was really more of a broad theoretical
paper, but Carlson was determined to make
it a reality.
Carlson would begin trying to do electrophotography
in his apartment which led to a bunch of smoke,
odd aromas, and even explosions.
His neighbors probably suspected that he was
smoking up something else, but Carlson persisted
and with the help of a friend, he would produce
the following piece of text on October 22,
1938.
Carlson was sure to patent this technology
as soon as possible and eventually, he would
partner with an up and coming company called
the Haloid Company.
And together, they would create what we all
know as Xerox today, but it was by no means
an easy road.
You see, there was one major flaw with Carlson’s
invention.
It was extraordinarily difficult to use.
To be honest, I think we’d agree that electrophotography
is probably easier than what we have today,
but nonetheless, Carlson wanted to make it
even easier.
With backing from Xerox, Carlson would spend
the next 21 years of his life trying to simplify
each and every step of the process.
And eventually in 1959, he would crack the
code with the Xerox 914.
This was the photocopier that was so easy
to use that even a Chimpanzee could use it
leading us into the golden era of printers
UNREASONABLY EXPENSIVE:
It may be hard to believe that printers were
actually good at one point in time, so I’m
sure you’ll be relieved to hear that there
was a massive caveat.
Yes, the Xerox 914 and all of the photocopiers
and printers that followed in the 60s, 70s,
and even 80s were extraordinary, but it wasn’t
just the product that was extraordinary; it
was also the price tag.
The cost to make a Xerox 914 was simply so
expensive that they didn’t even try to sell
it.
Instead, they resorted to renting them out
to local photocopying shops and offices for
$25 per month or $238 today.
Additionally, customers would have to pay
10 cents per copy or 96 cents today.
Customers were also responsible for bringing
their own paper and ink which usually ran
about 5 cents per copy.
So, all in, customers were paying over a dollar
for every single page they were printing.
The only people who were able to get around
renting was the US government as they were
dead set on buying these outright.
They would get their wish but it would cost
them an absolute fortune coming in at $27,500.
That’s the same as $262,000 today.
Photocopying was obviously not cheap, but
it was more than worth it for important documents.
I mean the consequences of losing a land deed
or bond certificate were far worse than spending
a dollar to have an extra copy.
This proved to be insanely profitable for
Xerox and by 1970, Xerox would become a Fortune
100 company which for a tech company was at
the time unheard of.
With all this revenue coming in, Xerox would
invest a crap ton of money into research and
development, and they actually came up with
outstanding inventions.
Not only would they make printers way better,
but they would literally invent laptops, the
internet, coding languages, text editors,
and so much more.
Now, they were so gung ho on printers that
they would end up giving all of these away,
but that’s a whole nother story.
The point is that they were truly maintaining
printers at the forefront of technology, but
with that, they were also charging an arm
and a leg and keeping up the renting model.
For obvious reasons, having people pay per
copy was a far better business decision for
Xerox than trying to sell printers outright.
But, the reality was that things were changing
once again.
The need to photocopy was quickly being replaced
by the need to print digital documents.
Fortunately, it was Xerox who invented text
editors and the ability to print text documents,
so they could serve this need as well, but
there was one problem, you had to go to a
Xerox shop.
If you were using a computer cafe, it made
sense to use the Xerox printer in the building.
But, while computer and internet cafes were
super popular back in the day, people would
eventually ditch these for personal computers
in the comfort of their homes.
And traveling to Xerox shops just to print
stuff out quickly became an inconvenience.
HP, Epson, and Canon were all watching this
from the sidelines, and they decided that
this was the perfect time to strike.
THE DEMISE OF PRINTERS:
The first mass market residential inkjet printer
was the HP Deskjet 500 which came out in 1988.
Like its Xerox predecessors, this was truly
an engineering masterpiece.
In fact, it was so good that journalists like
Scott Merrill were raving about 22 years later.
“The HP DeskJet 500 was a workhorse.
It never failed me in college, or beyond.
I printed a lot, and never had a paper jam.”
“Everything I threw at the DeskJet 500,
it printed.
Everything.”
But, if printers were so good, what happened?
Well, it turns out that asking people to pay
$1000 for a printer in 1988 was a pretty large
ask.
With budget computer brands like Dell popping
up, you could literally buy an entire computer
for that price, so why would you spend the
same amount on just getting a printing machine?
Well, the answer was that most people wouldn’t.
If these companies really wanted to create
a personal printer market, they had to make
printers cheaper, way cheaper, but this was
much easier said then done.
Just because computers offered better value
for your money didn’t mean that it was any
cheaper to design or produce printers.
But, that was irrelevant to end consumers.
If you wanted to appeal to them, it was up
to you to figure out how to make printers
cheap enough for everyday people.
With all these mega companies working on this,
you would think that some engineer somewhere
would make a monumental breakthrough that
substantially simplified printers and made
them far cheaper, but this never happened.
Instead, printer manufacturers just decided
to sell printers for a loss.
They figured they could just make the money
on the ink, and somehow 30 years later, they’re
still using the same strategy and they’ve
only gotten more aggressive.
The reason that printers are affordable today
is not because they’re cheaper to make but
because companies are willing to take bigger
and bigger losses.
But, with that being said, when you’re selling
a product for a loss, you’re naturally not
going to invest into R&D, testing, reliability,
or ease of use.
Instead, you’re gonna put out an MVP or
a minimum viable product, and this is the
reality of the entire consumer printer industry
today.
The reason printers are so bad is because
every company is trying to shrink an extremely
complex product into an MVP.
I mean just think about.
A printer has to put millions of dots onto
a piece of paper within a matter of seconds
seconds.
There’s no way that such a complex product
can work as an MVP that’s sold for a loss.
Printer companies should be thinking about
how to engineer better printers, but given
that that’s not where the money is, printer
companies have been spending all of their
efforts on how to sell as much ink as possible,
and this has led to some pretty anti-consumer
inventions.
Some companies will straight up prevent you
from using counterfeit ink through software,
but even if they don’t go that far, they’ll
make sure that you feel that pain.
For example, the printheads of many printers
are actually located on the ink cartridge.
This means that the quality of your print
will only be as good as the ink you buy.
So, if you bought some counterfeit cartridges
and noticed that the quality went down substantially,
this is probably why.
A BLEAK FUTURE:
Looking forward, the future of printers isn’t
looking any brighter because printers as a
whole are going extinct.
Here’s the thing, one of main reasons that
printers became so popular in the first place
was because of trust.
People didn’t trust computers as much as
they trusted themselves.
They wanted to have hard copies of important
documents, they wanted real signatures that
felt authentic, they wanted something real.
But, today, printers are becoming irrelevant
for the exact same reason trust.
This time though, it’s themselves that people
don’t trust.
People and companies alike don’t want to
have filing cabinets full of documents.
They don’t want to hold onto 200 page contracts
that are fatter than books.
And they trust the cloud and 7 backups across
the world more than a singular hard copy.
At this point, hard copies are more of a formality
than anything.
Everything from buying a house to completing
an acquisition can be done completely digitally
and this is what people actually prefer.
So, with that being said, it doesn’t make
sense for anyone to double down on the printer
industry and try to make it better.
The reality is that printers are going extinct
and the last memory that we’ll have of them
is good riddens.
Do you hate printers?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you trust computers more
then yourself.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.